hier tu pensais que tu étais une fille normale
aujourd'hui tout ton monde a été bouleversé
ce que les gars sont nouveaux inconnus une arnaque pas un
banal qu'est-ce qu'un banal quelqu'un du
monde humain
eh bien pas un humain et quoi que tu
ne me croirais pas si je te le disais
tout ce que tu as entendu sur les
cauchemars des monstres ils sont tous réels tu as un
don incroyable et nous avons besoin de toi j'ai besoin de
toi ta mère était une Chasseuse d'Ombres
comme lui comme ici des êtres d'un
pouvoir immense assez fort pour protéger l'humanité
dans une guerre contre le mal le monde  on lui demande
de prendre
il y a une carte dans ta tête
Clary tu es la clé de
notre survie  beaucoup d'entre eux
me laissent te montrer qui tu es vraiment qui
tu étais destiné à être tu ne
sais rien de moi
toi